hello everybody and welcome back to cry
of fear okay I gotta inject myself with
more stuff cuz the hands touched my feet
and I just crumbled like a little girl
oh yeah okay all right
where are we going what are we doing
getting in a regular space no what makes
you think that home is going to be any
better half of the cities like this
Harlem is probably not so it's dark it's
nothing don't worry there's a totally
black 52
there we
all right
no another useless hole I will dice a
few okay this looks more normal at least
but still night time gosh
can it day yet crazies crazies
those out there are you okay you better
come home now I'm getting worried
oh don't worry I just killed like 15
zombie men hide another dummy man wha
what truck huh what oh ho
wham miss OH what you did
don't worry police I just killed this
guy whose self-defense
where's Locke whoa
Ronald Street says here that I can take
the subway from Hanson square to get
home
Saxon Saxon Avenue first and where is
this this is a normal city this can't be
normal
handsome square through sex again oh man
it's not normal up blood all over the
police car not good not good
Oh what is that what is that what is
that what is that it's got faces oh not
touching that okay I hear ya
oh all doing can I go through that door
will it take my head off ah no no sorry
bro
sorry oh there's a guy behind you is it
dude oh man
freaky okay but where do I go maybe I
got to shoot it probably kilo yeah but
car okay that did nothing um okay that's
that's not doing anything I'm just
wasting maybe my sprint by haha oh come
on
well f you to buy good guy can go
backward to the point where I didn't
waste time all right
oh no hope things are normal oh there's
just normal oh oh and he's crazy gonna
jump out of me done nothing Oh card oh
are you okay you better come over now
I'm getting worried I don't know how not
just some crazy you ah yeah okay
so that doors locked I probably got to
find a key to go oh what about here
locked uh
okay let's see this cutscene
you take the subway from Hanson Square
to get home you had to Saxon Avenue
first okay gotta find out where all
these places are cuz idea okay so
there's the weird tree of death here
here excuse me Oh car use with your car
so scary Saxon Avenue is that way but I
can't cut it so I'm gonna find like a
door that I can why does it sound like
there's bees
everybody gets bees
fine obviously going down that way is
not the right answer
oh here we go okay miss that
haha fooled you Oh where'd you go
where'd you go where'd you go where'd
you go where'd you go what happened why
what the hell oh oh you got some
tentacle action going on there oh let's
go what is wrong with this city what is
going on no no no no I do not know
shotgun shells please yes some way down
[ __ ] dinner get out of there
ah oh my goodness oh you're trapped
aren't you ha ha ha ha beat the pinata
oh so sad oh you did get more dead
beaten by your own diabolical
machinations what a tragedy on upon
itself but Franco would fam flame them
okay ah wow you're fast
no no oh you guys look like you want
some shot go but it doesn't pause the
game
oh oh oh what'd you get go
that guy oh look at it
oh you're another trapped one who give
you my gun reloaded now see never know
when you're gonna need two bullets oh
okay you don't even try don't even try
oh poor little baby
Oh fu hey what the fu ah
oh excuse me while I inject myself right
here just hold on one moment here
Oh stuff what about alright hold on a
little more little are you okay there
buddy you all right
oh thank you for waiting how nice of
them
the shotgun is powerful Oh walsim oh oh
you what what oh thank you for waiting
you're so patient these guys they're
just patient very well-mannered thank
you sir thank you
all right Oh walsim whoa I see you come
on down
oh you're one of those chained up guys I
can beat you oh god not two of them all
Adam pots get get it get get down they
didn't move what the heck guys just shot
guns get shot by this you're supposed to
die that's your cue to die I got stop
wasting my shotgun shells so it's my bad
tone huh what no one hey you better what
huh okay chained up I can't open it but
I'm so strong I'm so strong to rip it
off it's
oh I haven't saved it like forever I
haven't saved since before what now
you're gonna throw an instant kill
monster at me when I didn't say for like
ten minutes ah okay all right I'm gonna
cut it here um in the next episode I'll
start it I'll be passed or I'll be right
up to that guy so you'll see me take him
down kick his ass cool yeah alright
thank you guys so much for watching and
as always see you in the next one bye
bye